okay so I interviewed the wolf wolf of
wallstreet Jordan Belfort earlier this
week and one of the things that came up
was Jordan saying I don't care what you
do I'm socially liberal but I'm fiscally
conservative and this actually makes no
sense and I want to discuss that with
you today very often the way that we
hear about someone being socially
liberal and fiscally conservative is
they'll say something like and I have
many friends who say this I want low
regulation I want low taxes I don't care
who gets married and I think women
should be allowed to choose abortion if
it's what's right for them well it
sounds plausibly coherent you're
socially liberal and you're fiscally
conservative well the the problem is if
you're fiscally conservative you almost
always have a position that is terrible
for the environment and for dealing with
climate change you might have social
liberal fiscal conservative
self-described who agree that the
science is right on climate change they
accept the science I think is better
said but if you're economically are
fiscally conservative you're not going
to deal with climate change almost by
the very nature of what it means to be
fiscally conservative you need
regulation to deal with climate change
fiscal conservatism is against
regulation under the guise of work for
small government and it's a direct
contradiction it doesn't make sense the
free market which fiscal conservatives
pray at the altar of in many cases will
not solve the climate crisis socially
liberal might mean you have empathy for
the poor and you want to fix
homelessness and deal with uninsured
Americans who have no health insurance
okay great but the problem is that
fiscal conservatism believes in tax
schemes that will not deal with the poor
and with homelessness and getting
everybody health care you can't do it
it's a direct contradiction you can say
it but it doesn't make it a logical
thing if you are fiscally conservative
you often repeat this idea we've got to
balance the budget I'm a deficit Hawk
we've got to reduce the deficit until a
Republican is president then you often
forget about it but if absent any
context
your priority is we've got a cut cut cut
to reduce the deficit you can't deal
with the social issues that you claim to
be liberal on you just can't do it so
very often when you hear someone say I'm
a centrist or I'm a social liberal and
fiscal conservative you're really
dealing with what's called the
right-wing libertarian these are
essentially right-wingers who don't hate
gay people right I mean this is a gross
oversimplification but when I hear
socially liberal fiscally conservative
in practice I hear I'm a right winger
but I'm not interested in persecuting
gay people another way to understand
socially liberal and fiscally
conservative is I really would love to
fix the issues that are affecting the
poor marginalized often minority
disenfranchised individuals but I don't
want the government to get involved and
definitely none of my tax money should
go towards fixing those problems it's
not a very principled or coherent
position that's the reality if you
support these social rights you have to
have an economy that's going to provide
and guarantee those rights otherwise
it's just nonsense there's a lot of
corporate CEOs that want to be relevant
that take this approach sometimes they
call it centrism
Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz is sort of
one of those guys he's a social
progressive about non discrimination in
the workplace he's for gay marriage all
of that stuff but economically he's
essentially a standard neoliberal who is
about free markets he's suspicious of
caricatures of socialism that float
around all of that stuff now the other
thing I will say is it's a very small
group of people who actually are
socially liberal and fiscally
conservative not when you say hey where
do you fall on the political spectrum
when you do a proper poll or test where
people are answering answering questions
about their beliefs the number of people
that are actually socially liberal and
fiscally conservative is very small you
pull people on the issues and you find
in many studies for example one done by
the voters study group whose results
were putting up on the on the screen the
area that is least common in this four
quadrant system so
for box where you can be socially and
economically liberal you can be socially
and economically conservative or you can
be a mix the least common quadrant is
socially liberal and economically
conservative it's actually far more
common to be socially conservative but
economically what we might call liberal
in the more progressive sense so even
many of the people claiming that they
are socially liberal and fiscally
conservative actually aren't but the
more important analysis is that it's
incoherent if you were socially liberal
and fiscally conservative the fiscal
conservatism essentially makes your
social liberal nacelle event
beyond just you don't hate gay people
and again it's it's a gross
oversimplification but it really
illuminates the contradiction if you
aren't going to be pushing for
regulating businesses in a way that
makes sense if you're not going to be
pushing for economic justice policies
being socially liberal in some yeah in
in name only way I guess is what I'm
saying is not really worth much in terms
of policy if you disagree with me let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show we
are going to take some phone calls
coming up and later on we are going to
get back to this issue of the regulation
of social networks and what should and
shouldn't be part of that that's coming
up later but much more right after this
short break
do you feel like you just don't have
enough time to become as intellectually
well-rounded as you would like to be
that they're just not enough hours in
your week for you to read all of the
books that you want to read one of our
sponsors is called blinka stand it's an
app that lets you consume an entire
non-fiction book in 15 minutes it's only
about eight bucks a month but you can
try it for free for a week and get 25%
off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio the
you can read or listen to in just 15
minutes and what you get is all of the
most important ideas and information
from the book imagine being able to
listen to an entire nonfiction book in
the amount of time it takes you to drive
or walk home from work I just finished
listening to catch and kill by Ronan
Farrow super interesting book probably
already familiar to some in my audience
and a really interesting take at how
Harvey Weinstein and his alleged
transgressions were brought to light
excellent investigative piece Blinky's
has totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for bling cast
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink as comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 20/20
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you